we don't often speak to the larger
broader World they don't like to pick
fights and then and then these articles
start to appear
my name is David zwibell I'm a rabbi I
am the Executive Vice President of
agurath Israel of America which is a
national Orthodox Jewish organization
there does appear to be
a concerted effort that is currently
taking place and has been taking place
place over the last number of months to
find various aspects of Orthodox Jewish
communal life
education social activities others to
portray it in a way which is very harsh
and very negative we are concerned that
it's not only troubling but even
dangerous to a certain extent and
something that we feel is simply unfair
they feel demonized justifiably and
would like people to get another side of
the story since nobody else is actually
articulating the other side of the story
so after the first couple of Articles
appeared in the times we got together
here at the headquarters of a good
Israel of America and we said should we
in some way engage the public just as
the times engages the public and
presents the correct and and you know
more appealing and proper view of whom
we are and what we do and that's when
this new project this new initiative
called know us was born and the reason
we chose that name is because
you won't know us
if you just go by all the negativity you
read in the New York Times it was
decided around that table that we we
needed to become a little bit proactive
and uh and depart from the strictures
that we usually operate within
and uh and announce to the world you're
being shown what an orthodox show is
it's not an accurate picture know us
look at what we have to say the no us
campaign is really one of the very first
times that I can remember in my many
years of communal activism where we've
gone so public in pushing back on a
particular issue and obviously because
of the environment and the climate that
we as a Jewish community and an Orthodox
Jewish Community are finding ourselves
with alarming rates of anti-Semitism it
was felt that something had to change
just ringing our heads and saying it's
terrible it's terrible and I get more
police protection which who we love but
it just simply wasn't happening it's see
what's happening in our beautiful world
in our community and then to have the
times portray us in a way like it looks
we're in some sort of an amusement park
fun house with the mirrors giving you a
distorted image of of of of of who you
are we know that's not who we are and we
resent that the times is starting to
portray us as something that we're not
and we and we resent that the times is
engaged in what appears to be a crusade
don't ask me I can't explain it but a
crusade to get people to consider
Hasidic Jews in a negative lighting they
visited a school where I know the kids
in that school can read and write and if
they visited that school they would have
seen that the kids can read and write
but they felt that that would not match
what they were trying to present so
instead they gave the the school's test
scores and said look these kids are
illiterate any reporter who walked into
the school would see these kids are
literate completely literate and yet
they portrayed it as if these kids were
completely illiterate
one because they were generalizing from
from the experiences of individual
schools
number two because it was all negative
not a word of positivity right and
number three the timing of it at a
moment in our history when anti-Semitism
was spiking so terribly I do know that
they
met with the New York Times I'm together
with other communal leaders to express
their concern about how this is being
reported
and were completely ignored there was a
meeting arranged
between several organizations
and and editorial leadership of the New
York Times to express concern about
the in the lack of balance
appears in these articles
it's part of that conversation as well
and probably the times would say that
that that that meeting was helpful and
and maybe led to a little bit of
more of a balance and the subsequent
articles but I haven't seen it
we felt that the point had been reached
where we couldn't simply sit back
silently and write letters to the editor
which would be published it wouldn't be
published and so on so when you're
waiting in traffic in front of the
Lincoln Tunnel you know you'll see this
this big billboard and and
see that there's a Jewish community over
here that is concerned about how they're
being portrayed in the times and one of
the sites that was intriguing to us was
a site I'm very very close to the New
York Times building
and uh I guess we didn't just want
um
commuters stuck in traffic to know that
we were concerned about the negative
image that was being portrayed in the
science but we wanted the times to know
that we were concerned you want to know
a little bit about Orthodox Jews you can
get whatever information you want from
the time so it gets to get to really
know us